well hey everybody surprise here we are
and it's Sunday yep I mean it was just
such a boring day today and yeah and we
saw an extra movie so we're going to do
an extra moview yeah we figured we would
just jump on at like a weird time yeah
whenever we were ready to do it and like
talk about it just because we to the
movie theater yesterday and so yeah we
saw saw this movie it was uh Godzilla
minus one yeah and it was epic it's
awesome this is a [__] great movie
it's a great movie yeah I think this
might be the best Godzilla movie I mean
this one and maybe the best one since
the original for sure and well like I
said I haven't seen I've seen a lot of
Godzilla movies but I haven't seen them
all I'm not like a Godzilla fan girl or
anything um how many have they made I
think they've all together there's 37
Godzilla movies 33 of them made by too
yeah so I've seen the the American ones
with Kong they're they're okay yeah I
don't really consider that to be
Godzilla though I mean it's there's
something about the way it looks it's
just not quite right um this looks like
Godzilla and even the Japanese ones have
gone through eras you know what I mean
so I feel like where they do reboots and
different looks and stuff yeah the
newest one before this was Shen Godzilla
that was that was a champ was from last
year and and it mixed reviews from what
I heard it was like yeah I think a lot
of people liked Shin Godzilla I thought
it was older than that though I thought
it was I thought it was from like 2017
or right something like that I'm not
entirely sure though because I think
there was another one um I don't know I
feel like this one was kind of inspired
by this one's inspired by the original
1954 Godzilla for sure yeah it's a
horror movie starts off as a horror
movie got damn and it's in World War II
that's when it's starts which I love
yeah it's the Japanese man these are all
Japanese it's all said in the 40s 1945
to 1947 I think is this ban of the movie
there very little English in it it's all
Japanese guys it's all period it looks
correct thank God it's not dubb the um
yeah it's not dubbed it's it's uh
subtitled [__] I hate
dubb and it starts off with some uh
mechanics aircraft mechanics out on this
little bitty Island and a uh kamic ay
pilot who his plane's there they're
working on it he evidently had to ditch
uh the plane wasn't working right so he
uh he ditched no his plane was working
perfectly yeah but that's not what he
told them but he told them that it was
right that's a spoiler though no it's
not they say that in all the reviews
this is like this happens like in the
first couple minutes of the yeah if
turns out turns out there was nothing
wrong with the plane he said there was
something wrong with the plane so he
didn't have to go on the comicazi
mission yeah which you can't blame while
he was there they got at at
night um um they heard something a bunch
of noise and this monster comes out of
the ocean and some of the Japanese
mechanics knew what it was they said
yeah the the locals have been talking
about this things they call it
Godzilla and um they tried to shoot they
tried to hide from it at first but then
it walked up on them and they shot it
and it attacked and it destroyed a bunch
of stuff and the the kamakazi pilot they
asked him to get into the plane and
maybe shoot it with 20 mm guns that was
on the on his comicazi playing that that
should kill
it now this he he he freezes though he
doesn't pull the trigger you got too
scared he was kind of a
coward um and he's the main character
for the rest of the movie uh because he
didn't pull that trigger that Godzilla
killed all his dudes they didn't go home
and uh he kind of felt like because he
didn't go on his kamakazi mission Japan
lost the war so he's trying to uh
overcome his basically basally feelings
of [__] being a coward by confronting
Godzilla when Godzilla finally shows up
in Japan it's a good flick man it's good
it has a lot it's really good it was
like I I had heard that it was just I
didn't watch or read any reviews prior
to it but I had just heard kind of just
generally that it's like oh my God this
is like an amazing Godzilla it's got
like all the critics love it it's just
all the audiences love it and I was just
kind of like um so I'm I don't know I'm
just going to add to that chorus though
because I thought this was a great
[__] movie and like I said I'm not a
Godzilla fan girl or anything like that
like I like Godzilla movies but they're
goofy I could take them or leave them
but this one I like this one because
much like the original 1954 movie it
took it seriously and this is going back
to the original idea of Godzilla as a
manifestation of the atomic bomb yeah
and and it's a monster and yeah and he's
scary yeah which like I said in a lot of
Godzilla movies he's not really scary SC
and he's part of the reason that he's
scary well he's just scary anyway but
part of the reason that he's scary is
because you actually give a [__] about
the human characters which is something
that I think a lot of Godzilla movies
struggle with yeah cuz most of the time
you're just kind of like I just want to
see Godzilla step on people and like
knock buildings down and [__] but this
one I didn't really want to see that
like I did but I didn't want the people
to get killed yeah they're showing the
Japanese people running from this thing
and they're just regular people and
you're like no it's crushed
yeah it's killing people um but it has
everything you come to expect from a
Godzilla movie um based on the very
first one it's got a mad scientist he
was my he was my favorite character yeah
he's trying to figure out how to defeat
I loved that guy uh Godzilla uh Brave
Naval captains uh ex-military
guys um dude trying to become a a family
man uh loyal Brave
woman um adorable child yeah it's got a
little cute kid in it not a Kenny he's
not a Kenny like Grandma she's not a
Kenny yeah but um there's a lot of real
positive messaging in it about you know
loss how to recover from loss uh how to
be a man has that in there uh that that
[__] isn't perfect you know um the how
to be a little selfless you know yeah it
has it has a lot to do with it how to
let things go like don't let things [__]
you up you know what I mean yeah also uh
good uh messages about patriotism and
everybody pulling together uh that don't
not be independent see unlike other
Godzilla movies the government couldn't
do [__] it was the people that were
fighting Godzilla it was a private it's
a
private it's a private organization they
put together real rapidly out of uh ex
uh ex military guys because the
government couldn't help and America
couldn't help America could because the
war was just over yeah and so there was
all these reasons that they couldn't
yeah America couldn't go down in there
with Force to fight Godzilla because uh
there the tensions with the Soviets the
Soviets [__] prevented that prevented
that and the Japanese government really
couldn't be dependent on they didn't
really have anything so the people had
to do it which that was kind of a cool
message like you know was don't let
others solve your problem you got to
[__] solve the problem you know and
they rise up to solve the problem and
they eventually you don't know if they
overcome it it's I don't doesn't seem
like Godzilla was destroyed um he would
temporarily put put at Bay but it looks
like he survived now there's some
differences with this one versus the
other
ones they kind of explain why why
Godzilla is impervious to things like
tanks and [__] you can blow a hole in
him you can basically kill him he just
Grows Right Back he heals up he
regenerates yeah well like a lizard
growing a tail back I guess is kind of
where they were getting that idea yeah
but it's fast enough where you can watch
it happening and he'll have scars there
but then then that'll that'll uh kind of
fade
too
um another thing is that you can
definitely hear the the Japanese actors
calling him G
yeah I thought that was that's not his
name in in in Japanese his name is
Gojira yeah with J go goira but for some
reason they said okay we're going to
call him go with a z
Godzilla which that's okay I guess
International markets I guess God to the
it nod to the international market his
real name is
Gojira um it's it's excellent flick uh
and when we were walking out of there
there was an old guy in front of me must
have been about 70 with his wife and he
goes that movie was a lot better than I
thought it was going to be it's a
serious split it is it's not like like
yeah there's there's monster Shenanigans
and monster destruction like you do get
to see Godzilla like stepping on [__]
and like knocking [__] over in Tokyo and
all coming up out of the ocean and
[__] up battleships and [__] like
that you get to see him doing that but
it's actually a really serious and I've
seen a couple reviewers say this it's
like this is this movie is so good that
you could even take the Godzilla [__]
out of it and it would still be good
yeah because all of the like the because
the character drama is so compelling
which you can't really say about a lot
of Godzilla movies because even even
some of the ones that I thought were
good that were like real epic and had
really cool like monster fights and [__]
like that you didn't really give a crap
about the humans this one you absolutely
do like um you really don't want to see
any of the characters get killed there's
a lot of emotional resonance really the
only criticism I've ever seen of this
are people being like well I don't want
to see like all these people people like
with the Drama character drama and all
that other kind of stuff I just want to
see Godzilla stepping on people and blah
blah blah but it's like I've seen like a
couple of dudes like say that kind of
crap but really no that's not this movie
that's not this
differentiates all the this is a very
different kind of movie it's not like a
normal Godzilla movie where Godzilla's
the main character and the the humans
are just bit parts and you just and
they're just filler for the you know for
the monster fod yeah St down and eaten
they they they they struck a happy
balance where Godzilla was his own
character and he was doing cool [__] and
he does a lot of cool [__] in it um he's
scary because he's not protecting Japan
like in most of the guns of the movies
he's [__] Japan up big time and
uh and uh the characters that are trying
to stop him and and you know are uh you
you know them you know them and you like
them and you know their motivations of
why they're trying to stop this thing
and um
you care about them if they get killed
you know so it's it's a good balance it
uh it's not like I remember in some of
the old Godzilla movies as soon as it
started talking about most of the scenes
in in a classic Godzilla movie are a
bunch of Japanese guys in suits in a
office in a big [__] at the top of
some building all telling other each
other what to do right that's what you
know they're planning what they're going
to do which was in the 50s you know that
was like the American equivalent of
dudes talking on the T or they're in the
office talking on the talking about the
monster threat and what they're going to
do about what they're going to do about
it there there's a lot of that a lot of
50 or shots of somebody arriving and
departing in a car a lot of that was in
Old Amer they're trying to stretch it
out to to like feature length that's
what they were trying to do there they
didn't have a big budget so uh but this
this one's Done Right definitely uh it's
a hit you know it's evidently doing well
in every Market that it's in and it's
only being uh played in certain theaters
R our AMC had it I mean if our AMC and
Dinky ass leberg had it I'm pretty sure
it's like pretty you can find it you can
find it because and people came out to
see it yeah there was we went yesterday
afternoon at like the 115 show yeah and
there was a lot of people and there was
a lot of people in there yeah so there
it's uh there was no promotion for this
it's all Word of Mouth it did get a big
Premiere in La okay um as far as I know
uh but I think they I don't know if
they're like it out slowly like limited
or if it's wide release now like I said
if it's at the AMC in lesburg I imagine
it's probably wide probably opening it
up cuz it's making money and it you know
what is amazing to me is that this movie
cost $15 million $15 million it's
nothing and it looks yeah incredible
yeah it looks better than a than it
looks better than a Hollywood I mean the
last Godzilla movies that they made in
what do they they call that the monster
verse right like they're like 200
million yeah they were like they're like
160 170 $200 million and it's like they
looked cool and everything like that but
this one looked just as good I thought
and it cost like a tenth of the that was
a tenth of the money here's the thing
about the American ones that that that
goes with the Kong one too I like Skull
Island Kong skull out of them all yeah I
did too actually I think that was
probably the best one the best one I
remembered the
most of that one the other ones were
totally forgettable I I enjoyed watching
them but then when they were over I
couldn't tell you what happened yeah
there's they're not very interesting
they're just spectacles you know this is
an interesting movie it's basically Jaws
part of the movie is Jaws dudes in a
rinky dink ship fighting something
that's much bigger than Jaws you know
what I mean yeah because there's a lot
of [__] that's like taken out of job
because that's kind of like one of the
plot points like after the main
character whose name is kichi by the way
um when he comes back from the war and
he's kind of like you know he comes back
and he has to live in this slum cuz the
whole city's been decimated or whatever
yeah burned down and he takes a job as
like essentially like a mind sweeper
like they're going and getting rid of
all the mines after the from the war
yeah and so and that's where he meets
like his little gang of friends which is
also great I like that they have like
the family thing like where he he just
ends up finding a baby with this woman
yeah and this baby the baby's not hers
but the you know everybody got killed
you know what I mean so she kind of just
adopted this baby and most people were
just abandoning babies right at this
time and so she just kind of like moves
in with his house cuz he feels bad for
her yeah and then they just kind of end
up shacking up or whatever so it's just
kind of like this little ersat family
that they thing and then he has like
these three buddies that he's on this
doing this like really risky job with
and that's kind of how they um come in
contact with Godzilla he's the only one
that saw it previous to it cuz it was
smaller the first time he saw it it got
bigger like later yeah when you first
see Godzilla like on the island he's not
full size right
evidently the was uh I was watching um I
think Midnight's Edge or one of the guys
from Midnight had another Channel a
great
Channel he was under the impression that
when the first time you see uh Godzilla
it's that he's in his unmutated form
that's what I thought that he's natural
right he got mutated later and got
bigger and and he and he changed a
little bit the way he looked yeah I
thought that he implied that and he and
he and he developed a lot of special
abilities like that damn the heat ray
movie but it makes an atomic bomb yeah
like a like a mushroom cloud kind sh
explodes it's [__] badass um and he
had to get really pissed for him to
unleash that you
know really
yeah and there's like a recharge time he
can't do it all the time I love it I
love it but uh when they first see it
it's not that big really it's the size
of a dinosaur yeah like it's big you
would [__] your pants if you saw it but
it's not nowhere near as big as yeah
when you see it later on and it comes
out of the water you're like
[__] yeah and it swims real well yeah
and then there's some things that they
Jenny they look like little F people
were saying they were calling them fish
The Dead Fish coming up but I looked at
them man they didn't look like fish they
look like sperm cells look like a d they
were definitely
fish I'm looking at that looked like cuz
that they showed it man and it looked
like they were fish it looked like a
foot long or 8 in Long sperm cell I
thought I thought he was spawning in
there no no no no that doesn't have
anything to do with anything okay one of
the things you knew that one of the ways
that you knew Godzilla was coming was
that all the deep sea fish like all
these dead deep sea fish would rise to
the top no good so they're either weird
looking fish from the deep sea or
they're fish that went through
decompression when they came up really
fast is why they looked weird like that
okay but
uh trying to think another thing that's
interesting about the movie is that
there's the guys on midnight Edge said
that these this was basically practical
effects that had been enhanced with
CG other it Godzilla doesn't look like
the American Godzilla thankfully it
looks like the Tojo this is a too movie
looks like too Godzilla suit what it
looks like but a lot better but like a
lot better A lot I like that they kind
of homaged yeah the man in the suit look
but still made it look like a real
creature if that it has huge feet
just like in the too movies it can't
lift its feet up very far so it just
crushes everything as it goes oopsie
sorry St there uh it's real bottom heavy
it's got big old fat legs on it just
like just like the the the the old
movies
um now they were saying that it's it's a
suit that's what you're seeing it's just
most of the time it's a
suit or a puppet and it and and they're
it's performing in miniatures evidently
the buildings are
Miniatures CG to kind of enhance it
that's that's I did see a little bit of
behind the scenes footage though where
they were constructing the monster in
you know like a 3D modeling program yeah
so I'm not really sure like you know
with the wireframe and everything were
saying it was a mix so it's well yeah it
probably is I kind of feel like a I mean
there's some shots where the boat is
trying to get away from it and
Godzilla's head's behind it coming up
out of the water it's like straight out
of Jaws and its head looks [__]
badass it doesn't it looks like the old
Godzilla which to me Godzilla's face
always looked like a cat it didn't like
didn't look like a lizard it looks like
a [__] evil cat
really a cat lizard it's the only way I
can describe it but it has the eyes and
everything and what was funny is that it
didn't
blink yeah that's right I never noticed
that and it did it doesn't blink I think
in the old Godzilla movies I think they
I think they made it blink later but
they never once showed it I guess maybe
when it was a guy in a suit they were
like yeah that's too much trouble it
blink no one's going to notice BL
probably not so they to Homage that they
never showed it
blink so well and what you were saying
about jaw is like the writer director
and visual effects guy on this who are
all the same person by the way whose
name is tekashi yamazi um he uh cited
Jaws as one of The Inspirations okay for
this film I could see it yeah and yeah
particularly the sequences where they're
out on the M the little sweeping boat
yeah and they get sent out on this
Mission and cuz all these American uh
battleships have been [__] up yeah and
they are like hey go out there and um
see if you can see godilla is big enough
to throw a destroyer they show a damn
Destroyer going through the air and hit
it's crazy oh it looks good yeah it does
the guys are on the ship watching it go
through the air oh [__] yeah they're
going oh [__] I think I said oh [__] in
the theater too when I saw that now uh
towards the end of the movie there's
this the big big main effort to defeat
Godzilla they launch it and uh the
kamakazi pilot he's able to get his
hands on an experimental aircraft that
actually did exist in Japan called a
shinden and so he he had a
shinden it was
uh but basically it was a back backwards
propeller plane it had a big Wing in the
back prop pusher prop in the back
pointed fuselage and a little canards in
the front it always look like it's
flying backwards but that was a real
plane they even we were working on a jet
version of it too but but he's got the
propeller version they got guns on it
and they've smuggled a bomb in
it and uh there's some other [__] but I
don't want to spoil everything but he's
he wants to fly around this thing and
bait Godzilla into the Kill Zone
basically where they're gonna I'm not
going to tell you what the plan is
either it's a good plan yeah and then uh
he's got a bomb in the nose they had it
they especially his his his buddies who
were the the the mechanics that he that
he met when when they one of them yeah
and then his friends cuz he was the only
dude that was left that that survived
seeing Godzilla so they they they knew
they'd seen Godzilla before um they had
a bomb he mounted a bomb in the nose and
he was going to ram it down um
Godzilla's
throat but I ain't going to spoil how it
happens [__] it's good it's pretty cool
um and um it's kind of left open the the
the you're not sure what it's obvious to
me if you know the series that Gojira
survives it yeah because you can't have
a Godzilla movie where you like kill
Godzilla at the end you know what I mean
because he's got to come back no it's
called Godzilla M minus
one I didn't know what it meant but I I
did the guys on Midnight's Edge knew
what it meant in in Japanese
culture after they lost the war against
the United States they would say that
they were starting from zero yeah that
Japan started from zero well this is
before even starting from zero or
they're starting at even more of a
disadvantage one yeah that's why it's
called minus one minus one yeah well see
I think that's why CU um okay so the
original Godzilla which came out in 1954
was very much concerned with like the
atomic bomb and all that kind of stuff
so I like that they went back to that
theme and I think it was genius to set
this movie
right after the end of World War II when
Japan's still all [__] up they're
still trying to rebuild everything
everyone's tired everybody's you know
relatives everybody knows people that
have loved ones that have been killed
and it's just kind of like all this bad
[__] happens to them they're living in
these horrible conditions and it's taken
place over several years yeah I think
it's like two years like I it's like a
twoe time it starts during the war yeah
like at the tail end the tail end of it
but then a couple then it goes probably
like 5 years I think it goes up to 1947
or 1948 Maybe okay so about three years
um but yeah CU I'm going by how old the
kid was and I think they did they do
show like markers like what like when it
is and I remember seeing 1947 I don't
remember after that that makes the movie
a lot more realistic in an old Godzilla
movie it's all happening now yeah so
they get all this [__] together in
[__] two days this is yeah this is
over like a time per over per years but
see I think it was like a great idea
because it's like so Japan is all
they're all [__] up they're like you
know we just we survived and we just
want to like you know pick up the pieces
basically and try to put our lives back
together and then all of a sudden this
big giant [__] lizard is you know
steaming toward Tokyo and they have to
do something about it and so the
government can't do anything you know
they are all [__] up it's like the US
can't do anything nobody can do anything
for them and so like all of these
exmilitary like all this it's kind of a
populist movie in the sense that they're
all just kind of like we're the only
ones that can do anything and I like
that like some of the dudes were like
yeah [__] that it's like we just
survived the war all my family are dead
it's like yeah I I'm not doing it and
you can and you can understand like why
people would think that they would have
died anyway though had they not tried
that yeah that's another thing that's
one thing they didn't consider well if
we do nothing we're going to die anyway
but they well yeah I'm sure that did
that did occur to them but they were
like I'll probably take my chances you
know what I mean but um but yeah so I
like that there was this theme of not
only Redemption for like the main
character because like I said he did
some kind of [__] up [__] at the
beginning um that he felt was like
dishonorable and he got [__] on because
of that but as went on um you kind of
saw these people just like all trying to
pull together like for the greater good
because they knew that no one else was
going to help them and they knew that if
they didn't do something then nobody
else was going to do anything and they
were all going to get [__] up you know
what I mean so I thought it was like a
really good I don't know I just thought
that was a really good idea to set this
during that specific time period because
it really gave it a lot more um I don't
know like it gave it a lot more like of
an emotional core I guess because you
could just feel all of these military
veterans and stuff like that they were
just like man we [__] over this [__]
you know what I mean they just went
through a war they were all messed up
and it's just kind of like and now we
have to deal with this [__] you know and
they just didn't want to do it like you
know what I mean so I really like I
really liked that aspect of it you know
I thought that was a good like for
dramatic purposes I thought that was a
really good conflict to introduce what
other films do we see this
year what other films do we see this
year yeah not what in the theater in the
theater we saw a voyage of the demer I
remember seeing that one yeah um what
was what was the um did we see a Tom
Cruz movie this year or was that last
year yeah we saw um um Mission
Impossible yeah that's what I thought
I'd probably put this above mission
impossible actually yeah I think I liked
this better than Miss I liked that
Mission Impossible movie but um they're
different I think I liked this one
better this is one of the better ones of
this year and I pretty much that's every
other review of this that I've seen like
other movie reviewing sites that I
subscribe to or channels um pretty much
everybody's saying that that it's this
is easily one of their favorite movies
of the Year Hugo says he got split
because there's spoilers he's gonna see
this yeah yeah yeah we understand Andy
said are you guys going to do a reaction
to the Fallout TV show teaser I have not
seen it haven't seen it I didn't even
know they were making that yeah so I'm
going to have to go look that up now I
don't know we don't usually do reaction
videos because we're not that we're not
on the ball yeah you know what I mean
just off the top of my head if they're
going to do a Fallout television show
it's going to be bad probably I don't
know I'm going to default towards gonna
suck they they tend to [__] video game
stuff up pretty bad um we we'll have to
see you know I I'll wait for somebody
else to watch it and I'll get feedback
off of it before I bother with it that's
kind of usually what I to be honest it's
like th okay so this movie I didn't
didn't even know that there was a
Godzilla movie coming out well it's not
like I don't really keep up you know
what I mean I keep up with horror movies
but I heard about this two days ago but
yeah so I just heard about it from Tom
and he's like oh we should go to the
theater and see that CU it's playing
here and I was like yeah okay you know
what I mean like I like Godzilla movies
okay they're fine but I was actually
surprised by how much I really like this
one I thought this was like a great like
I said even if godz well yeah Godzilla
needs to be in it cuz he's like a really
good part of it but I like that it
didn't I like that they didn't skimp on
the other parts of the movie yeah like
yeah all the Godzilla [__] is like super
epic and everything but all the human
stuff is really really good too oh yeah
and I think that this is maybe the only
Godzilla movie I've seen other than the
original one that took care with the
characters and made like a whole story
arc for all these characters that you
gave a [__] about the original Godzilla
movie from from the 50s when I saw it as
a kid scared me it was like a horror
movie it has a tone like that yeah this
movie has that same tone it's better but
it's it's a kind of a remake of that
movie in some ways um they're going to
try to recapture what that original was
and I say yeah they they succeeded that
was a great idea yeah I think it kind of
topped the original but it's right up
there with the original it's it's not
[__] on the original it actually
took the best stuff from the original
and then they even improved on it and
they even uh homaged the the [__]
score the [__] they all the dramatic
[__] yeah score when you first see go
jiren or Godzilla [__] that's that
sounded like it was right from the
original movie and I like too that they
didn't and I noticed this when I was
watching the movie most of the movie
doesn't have a score yeah I guess it
doesn't doesn't it just comes yeah it
comes in like when there's like real
dramatic [__] happening but the rest of
the time there wasn't any which actually
did I did notice that yeah like in a lot
of the quieter scenes when it's just
like characters talking and stuff like
that like dramatic scenes they don't
have any it feels itic as [__] too I
mean you know just
because it's all Japanese
language uh good Japanese acting they're
taking the [__] seriously um the
costumes the settings you know it it's
the vehicles everything it it's 40s and
it [__] it takes you back to that
time even though I never lived in Japan
in the 40s it looks like that's what
it's taking place you know yeah and uh
there's a great scene where
Godzilla's [__] downtown it wasn't
Tokyo I forgot what city it was Ginza
Ginza that's right they're downtown in
Ginza and on top of the building is a
Japanese news reporting team yeah and
he's and the the Japanese reporter man
he's trying to actually wasn't
television it's radio was it yeah he's
doing his radio broadcast from the top
describing to the jab these people what
the [__] is happening you know
Godzilla's right next to our beloved you
know what was that something other
theater theater you know and then he's
destroying and [__] he's watching it
from the top of the building and [__]
and Godzilla come and [__] knocks
that building over and they falling they
they show them [__] sliding falling
dying and [__] it was [__] good man
it good it was straight out of the
Hindenburg film broadcast yeah I'm sure
I'm pretty sure that's what they were
broad oh the humanity oh the humanity
like [__] as the [__] God is
the yeah yeah perfect they nailed it
they nailed it that was a great scene
but the thing about it epic flick
because um Tammy was saying Son of
Godzilla was a comedy yeah and I feel
like there have been a lot of comedic
well I mean look at all the Godzilla
movies that had Mina in them you know
what I mean baby Godzilla bit like baby
Godzilla yeah and um you know I I just
kind of feel like some they they kind of
for a time went for like oh it's
Godzilla it's like a kids movie yeah and
he's protecting Japan he's a good he can
even dance that's like some gam [__]
right they went for the kids right and I
I you know this is very much not a kids
movie yeah like I said there's not
really much humor in it um
it's you know it's very focused on the
aftermath of World War II and like how
[__] horrible these people's lives
are and [__] like that and now they're
getting and now here comes Godzilla like
to step on them and they have to do
something about that and they're just
like man why the [__] you know after all
of this so you know what I mean so I
like that there's not I there's like a
little bit like moments of levity in it
but there's not really any comedy in it
which I actually really appreciate it
they really do take it seriously this is
a serious monster it's a serious threat
yeah they're not making a joke out of it
they're not they're just like oh [__]
like Here Comes This [__] gigantic
well they let you know this is going to
be a horror movie and it's serious right
off the bat yeah on on the damn Island
when unmutated Godzilla in his natural
form is he's bigger than a Tyrannosaurus
Rex but he's but basically that's what
you're dealing with but he's not as big
as and he kills a bunch of people right
and uh
you know it's pretty brutal it's cool
yeah he's just flinging people and and
the kamakazi pilot he had a damn PTSD
behind that kept and then later on when
he was doing the Mind sweeping job he
sees it again and it's bigger yeah it's
it's pretty good he's sh he told he told
him what it was I know what that is I've
seen that before yeah way bigger than
last time I saw it like like two years
ago or whatever it was so it grew like
to a much bigger sience like in the inm
um yeah Andy says Amazon Studios is
making it the Fallout show uh it's
coming out April 12th 2024 as a huge
Fallout fan I watched it with low
expectations but was pleasantly
surprised uh he also they have a way of
ruining things especially when it comes
to video game movies we'll see I mean if
it's
actual fans of the show or fans of the
movie of the video game maybe you'll
have something there but chances are
it's been purchased by a company that uh
and they're going to try to [__] put
their message across they're just going
to use that as a vehicle that's probably
what it's going to be that's usually
what it is that's usually how they do it
so I wouldn't get your hopes up I when
when it comes to any of these modern
series I'd start the ball real low I
wouldn't expect much now if it comes out
good then you're
lucky and then if it stays good you're
lucky or it'll go the way Mandalorian
did where only the first two seasons
were any good
you know they just they have a way of
[__] [__]
up Andy also says World War II and
Godzilla such an interesting combination
it does sound intriguing yeah I really
liked like I said I didn't really know
anything about this movie other than it
was a Godzilla movie like before we went
to it so I wasn't aware that it was like
set after World War II but while I was
watching it I was sitting there going
man this was a [__] genius idea like
putting Godzilla in this context it just
worked really really well yeah yeah they
were out on these little
islands and
um it was something that the what what
the Japanese called The Primitives knew
about it kind of like Kong Kong on Skull
Island it's kind of like that yeah they
didn't go super into it but they did
imply that it just implied the natives
on this it was Odo Island was what it
was where these mechanics were yeah he
says the natives called that thing yeah
they they had seen it before they knew
they they've been talking about that
thing you yeah but that was this was the
first time that it out of the you know
of course it was nowhere near as big as
it gets but it was still pretty big
bigger than a Tyrannosaurus Rex yeah cuz
there's just kind of like I would even
call that sort of like a prologue like
that happens on Odo Island where that
monster attack happens when Godzilla's
still relatively small and then there's
like then it jumps ahead you know what I
mean and then there's like a long
sequence that's just kind of focused on
the human characters before Godzilla
comes back out again and he's like way
way bigger like that time yeah
but yeah like I said so big that he
comes out and you King and just [__] up
like a battleship and stuff yeah and he
could have destroyed it its head went
right in front of the Cannons he didn't
pull a trigger yeah he froze up and that
was before the mutation happened so it
wouldn't have healed up he would have
killed it right so he felt survivors
guilt and guilt for that because that
thing ended up killing everybody on the
damn island or all his friends on the
island Japanese guys yeah yeah so he
just like carries that burden like for
the rest because he just like feels like
a loser and then like obviously because
was a comicazi and he didn't go through
with his yeah they alive he chickened
out so when he gets back to where he was
like the few surviving people are like
you know that's dishonorable and they
were like you're a piece of [__] you're
a coward like we lost the war because of
people like you right so he wasn't
having a good time so he was he was
really not um not feeling good when he
came back and and the Japanese civilians
didn't know they didn't know the details
of the war if you actually look at the
numbers they had no chance they had no
chance of making it I saw a uh bravery
wasn't enough um I once saw a dam
graphic
illustration of the amount of support
equipment behind the Japanese fighting
man and behind the American fighting man
of how much equipment was behind his
effort for every one Japanese soldier
there was really only a couple hundred
pounds of material behind him uh in
support for every American soldier in
the Pacific Theater there was like 30
tons of [__] support material behind
them just in the weight of the ships and
tanks and ammo and food you
know it was a David and Goliath type
situ Now worse it was you know they were
pipsqueaks they had reason why they lost
I'm getting off story but they lost
because they had Victory
disease they'd been winning against
China for so long they thought they knew
what they were doing but they had never
fought against an industrial power that
could just make ships and tanks like
they were nothing you know to by the
time they realized what it was like
fighting American soldiers in the
American Army it was kind of too
late they they tried to build a new Army
but it and a new Navy but it would was
was would never be ready in time well to
me like while I was watching the movie
and this actually occurred to me while I
was watching the movie I said I think
that's what makes this even more
emotionally resonant to me because when
kichi the main character when comes back
to you know his decimated Hometown and
everybody's dead like the few people
that are remaining are like yeah we lost
the war because of cowards like you
everybody and I think that the director
was saying well everybody in the
audience knows that's not true it
wouldn't have made any difference any
difference but he's still being made to
feel like that and he still feels like
that even though it probably wouldn't
have made any difference you know what I
mean and the thing about it is like even
if he had been able to shoot Godzilla in
in the plane that might not have killed
it you know what I mean it might have
but it might not have so it's just kind
so he's like beating himself up for
stuff that might not have made any
difference in the long run which to me
made it like even sadder 20 millimeter
would have handled that I know what 20
millimeter would do and that thing was
not because it wasn't its ma its main
size yeah it wouldn't have done anything
to have [__] mutated
Godzilla but it's original yeah he might
have got so maybe he should have felt
bad about that he would have blown his
head off but whole thing about him not
him not going through this kamakazi
Mission and people being like yeah we
lost the war because of you like not
because of you specifically but because
of cowardice and it's just like I don't
really think that that would have made
any like if he had gone on his kamakazi
mission I don't think it would have made
an Iota difference they hit the American
Navy with as many kamakazi attacks as
they could muster and it didn't make a
difference it did damage but it there's
just too many ships yeah that's what I
means in the long run it wouldn't have
made a difference it just delayed it for
a few months but like I said that's what
made him kind of like a tragic character
was because he was getting blamed for
that well he was blaming himself for it
for not going through with it because he
was a coward even though it wouldn't
have made a difference so I think like
as the movie goes on they kind of
address that a little bit where it's
like you know we're expecting these
young men to go and like kill themselves
do this and it probably wouldn't have
made any difference in the long run well
the the message that lets the audience
know that the Japanese were wrong about
the kamakazi making a difference is the
inclusion of a of something in the story
called an ejection seat yeah in which
when you see the movie you you'll
understand what I'm talking about
yeah the kamakazi attacks would have
only just delayed the inevitable a few
months it wouldn't have mattered yeah so
really he would have died for nothing it
was better that he lived yeah that's
what I mean and I'm saying that and I'm
saying that to me that made his parents
told him to come back alive yes and he
said I did do that yeah which that was
actually the right thing come back alive
and that's well I kind of thought that
was cuz that was kind of a whole
underlining theme of the movie too was
that um you in a way you kind of have to
like choose to live or like choose to be
happy because he was so [__] up by the
stuff that he had done and so um plagued
with self-hatred because of what he had
done that he wouldn't allow
himself to live right you know what I
mean yeah and then the overall his
overall story arc was ridic
Redemption and uh basically how to
become a man yeah he became a man he
with by adopting a wife and a child
basically yeah and and became because he
didn't want to be the father but
eventually he he becomes the father yeah
like he steps up to so he becomes a man
that's that's what the story AR but
that's great message he took
responsibility yeah doing his duty yeah
that was kind of like really kind of the
whole thing behind it and like I said he
was a great character all the acting in
this was really good too but I think
like the the Mad scci well he wasn't a
mad scientist but um kind of like the
Egon he was like the Egon of this movie
they just called him doc yeah and um he
was great I loved him he was the one
that came up with he had worked for the
Navy during the war like as a technical
like he was a weapons didn't he say he
was like a weapons designer or something
like that something like that and um so
then after like when they have to fight
Godzilla he's the one that comes up with
the plan you know what I mean and he
comes up with this like really cool like
elaborate plan yeah he's kind of like uh
he's homaging a lot of the the Mad
brilliant scientists from all the other
monster movies Japanese monster movies
you're going to have to have some kind
of mad scientist there it's gonna come
some stuff kind of like Egon out of
[__] from Ghostbusters from
Ghostbusters or uh the guy uh who plays
the uh the dude in [__] uh Jurassic
Park U yeah yeah yeah what's that what's
that guy's name um yeah I know what
you're talking about you know what I'm
talking about yeah yeah that dude what's
that what's that actor's name well now I
can't don't put me on the spot I can't
remember you guys know who I'm talking
about yeah I know who you're talking
about I just can't think kind of the
charismatic kind of likable scientist
he's kind of got crazy hair and he's you
know softspoken and nice guy you know
and he's going to come up with some
brilliant ideas and you have to listen
to me kind of a nerd nerd type guy yeah
but he's right I mean I always like that
kind of yeah I always like when it's
nerd power you know what I mean yeah
it's kind of nerd power well and well
and another thing that I liked and this
also occurred to me while I was watching
the movie is I like that they had the
mad scientist nerdy character who came
with the plan and everything I feel like
in some older Godzilla movies that I've
seen they made that character almost
like comic relief yeah but this one they
didn't like yeah he has like kind of
it's not crazy hair but it's like you
know unusual hairy hair is and he's just
and they kind of set him up like that
but he's not funny like he's actually
like a really honorable like really good
character yeah Jeff Goldblum thank you
Jeff I could remember that mother I
could see his face and I couldn't
remember that motherfucker's name to
save my life yeah there's a great um
brain cells are dying kids there's it's
a great scene where they have kind of
like the
traditional uh uh Godzilla scene where
all the military leaders and the
government and the scientist guys and
the media are all coming together to
figure out what they're going to do it's
like that okay and uh they're going oh
[__] this we don't want to do that man
we're we'll all get killed we know what
kind of crazy plan well scientist drops
his nuts he jumps on the damn
mic and uh starts telling the pl
and he wins he wins some of them over
now some other guys some other
characters have to come in
and you know convince the crowd but uh
that the the mad scientist character
really kind of shows his uh his worth as
kind of like a leader during that thing
that he steps up and shows how they're
going to destroy how he plans to destroy
Godzilla and we have you know the work
he goes I can't guarantee it that was
kind of cool about I like that he's
honest about that cuz they're like well
is this going to kill him he's like well
I can't guarantee that he's a scientist
they know there's no 100% certainty I
like that and yeah and to see see thing
is in an old Godzilla movie he just just
slide and said
yes but like they made him honest he's
like I don't know I don't know maybe
yeah yeah he's kind of like a Mito Kaku
guy yeah young meak yeah a little bit he
did kind of remind me of that a little
bit but
yeah it's a classic flick man I'm going
to ow I'm going to buy it I'm GNA own it
it was yeah it was like surprisingly
good yeah yeah yeah it was surprisingly
good yeah and uh they leave it to where
they let you know that another one's
coming and you know too did a good job
on this one as long as they hold the
course I'd like to
see Mothra
maybe what happens if they go M I would
like to see I would like to see a Mathra
in done in this kind of context that
would be cool actually who El could they
Mothra is always kind of my favorite
Godzilla adj mon you could have you
could have marra what about monsters
zero oh well no okay when you have the
Ali to okay yeah I like that gadra
gadora yeah or whatever they call King
gadora yeah King gadora yeah you could
do that you could have Godzilla come
back Fight King
gadora yeah you could have Destroy All
Monsters eventually where they have them
all there yeah yeah there was one but
you have to make it believable it's got
to be serious see and that's the
challenge cuz like I said this one was
serious as a heart attack like I said
this was very grounded in reality there
wasn't anything goofy about it there
wasn't anything I mean this was Godzilla
was like terrifying in this he's biting
trains and [__] cuz you could imagine
like I said there was absolutely nothing
funny about this at all because it's
like you if you saw this happen in real
life you're like well we're [__] yeah
he blew up a whole cities like atomic
bomb with his breath yeah yeah he just
[__] and then they showed like the
after
and it killed like 30,000 people or some
[__] like that yeah so it was just kind
of like absolutely nothing funny about
this at all it wasn't goofy it wasn't
cuz like I said I kind of feel like some
of the Godzilla movies even some of the
Japanese ones it's like hey look he's
stepping on Miniatures and it's like
[__] like that but I'm like he's
stepping on actual real human beings
like and this actually kind of shows the
weight of that yeah like of him actually
you can see him like [__] stepping on
these terrified people yeah well not
only that is that you had the damn uh
news reporting crew the radio crew they
introduce them kind of like their
characters and you get to feel you get a
feel for who this guy is they show his
ass gu Godzilla I was like wow they're
either Really Brave or really stupid
like if they're trying to bring
everybody the latest Godzilla news yeah
got their ass killed because of it but
you know what I mean he went down doing
his job yeah and like I said May and I
think that was kind of like a little
microcosm of kind of like that was his
duty he had to tell the public what was
going on get the information out there
and he did he just went down doing that
so good for him it's like they got it
directly out of the damn Hindenburg
transmission it was exactly I think oh
the humanity oh the humanity yeah yeah
so for some reason as usually happens
when me and Tom are having a discussion
about something yeah is that in the car
on the way home it occurred to me I was
like there's got to be Godzilla porn
right I was like where where Godzilla is
just like knocking over Tokyo with his
big giant dick or whatever so I was like
so obviously when I get home I'm gonna
like okay I'm gonna look up Godzilla
porn and uh I'm like yep um I mean I
could have I would have bet a million
dollars that there was because there's
porn of everything but yep there's lots
of Godzilla porn and I said and I told
him I said and there's also an
interesting little subgenre of porn of
Godzilla raping King Kong oh [__] so we
just got
demonetized these are fictional
characters
YouTube you know I'm just saying it's
and it's all drawn obviously it's not
[__] real although I'm sure there's
some porn out there of people in suits
that would be fun but I didn't see any
of that but I just saw like the drawing
with so uh this one gets uh a thumbs up
from me and Jen I'd recommend it see it
in the movie theater if you haven't seen
a movie lately and you want to have a
good time take somebody go see this in
the movie it's worth it you'll like it
if you like
Jaws if you
like good Godzilla movies just monster
movies yeah you like this one it's good
yeah and like I said it's a good balance
of like character drama with like some
really awesome like monster destruction
and I'm glad they didn't dub it it's
subtitled so it's sounds awesome I mean
it's authentic the ACT you can tell the
acting is good yeah that dubbing drives
me crazy the the only time that dubbing
doesn't really bother me is in giala
movies because I know that they just
like dubbed all of those because they
were just kind of like whatever there is
no original langage there's not really
not really because everybody just kind
of spoke their own language and they're
like we'll just dub it over in lots of
different languages and releas them all
over the world but any other foreign
movie I always want to see its original
language it's too distracting um knowing
that that's not the person's voice yeah
you know what I mean it distracts me too
much and it just I can't concentrate and
it and you can tell that they're being
recorded in a studio it doesn't sound
like it's on location right that too you
know that too yeah because you can
always tell the difference between
because they even do this in in all
movies but you know they do ADR where
you know they add in lines in post-
production like it's like oh we didn't
we didn't get that on location or we had
to add some dialogue in or something
like that and they added in later and
there's always a slight difference in
the sound like you can always tell the
difference so I kind of feel like maybe
that's what like when movies are dubbed
it's like yeah that sounds like it's
inside a studio and not like outside on
a beach or wherever they are you know
what I mean yeah and this one you can
tell they're you get the Sensation that
they're out on the ocean in this little
wooden damn boat the size of the Orca
when that what was the name of that that
what was I think it was called the orc I
think it was called the Orca yeah yeah
the bow and Jaws yeah B and Jaws the one
that that they're going to need a bigger
one it was Japanese it was even
painted yeah it was a well they they
explain that it's a wooden boat
because yeah because koichi goes to work
on it because he's like oh well it's
good money even though it's like super
dangerous and he goes there it's this
rickety ass Wooden Boat he's like yeah
we're going to go look for mines he's
like oh well it has to be Wooden Boat
because you know the US had magnetic
mines and if you had a metal ship then
you know the M be attracted to it and'll
blow up so you have to have like a
wooden one so it looks like this little
[__] rickety ass boat and they're
going out like scooping mines out of the
water like blowing them up like over
there but yeah so yeah um yeah if you
want to go to the theater and see
something really good then this one's
really good yeah I mean it's not gonna
be the same seeing it on uh screen on
television yeah probably not I kind of
feel like this is definitely one that
needs to be seen real Qui we set up
close we were like third row back yeah
we usually sit up in the third row
because not a lot of people sit up there
that's why cuz I don't like sitting by
people
Y and when we were there before do you
remember do you remember you were saying
like we were waiting for the movie to
start and do you said you remember when
that [__] came in here and tried to say
that we were sitting in her seats yeah I
don't even remember seat I don't even
remember what movie that was it was a
long time ago but yeah they have like
AMC probably other theater chains too
they all have a sign seat now you know
you buy the tickets and then they're
like hey where do you want to sit and
then they tell you where your seat is
right she was just tripping she comes up
with all these kids and tries to Caren
her way into the [__] seats yeah oh
these are my seats I was like m
no yeah I said no I got receipts for it
and then she just walked away it's like
what the [__] are you trying to pull
yeah it's like there was other empty
seats [__] off yeah like what are you
trying trying to take our seats yeah
even though like I said there was lots
of empty seats I don't really know what
her deal with she just wanted to like
drop her nuts I guess yeah she didn't
have any nuts though that's the problem
no nuts she wanted to drop her ovaries
yeah just big old big old fat chick
bunch of kids kind of a fat white trash
type chick yeah like I said [__] out
here trying to Caren way to I don't know
what that was all about I slap a [__]
get the [__] out of
here I got my receip yeah it's like move
move yeah yeah you piss off can you move
those are my
seats that I think that's what she said
um I said no I got my seat right here
and she didn't work
[__] nice try yeah so what are you
gonna do sit on sit on me if I say no
okay yeah know think so it's 2019 I'll
slap a bit or whatever year it was I I
don't think it was that long ago but
yeah yeah probably
2021 it's 2021 I'll slap [__] yeah
exactly try to get my [__] theater
seat when the whole [__] place is
empty God damn it it's like go sit
somewhere or better yet go home and
watch the movie how about that with all
of your little crotch fruit all
right I'm just saying all right all
right so we're going to wrap this up
we'll be back back again tomorrow and
we're doing the the twofer like we did
with The Haunting in Connecticut last
night we watched a haunting in Georgia
from 2002 I believe and The Haunting in
Connecticut 2 Ghosts of Georgia from
2013 so we're going to be talking about
those The wrick Haunting which both of
those are based on um so that should be
pretty fun also today I finished writing
up um a video for my scare Salon Channel
cuz I haven't posted anything on there
for several weeks and I thought it was
about time um I did another cuz if
you've been watching my videos over
there like I do a series like I'm doing
my top five favorite horror movies from
every year since I was born so I'm on
1982 now so hopefully in the next day or
two I'll get that recorded and um you
know and edited and uploaded so look out
for that and I'm also going to be doing
a couple at least one movie review this
week like a live stream I'm not sure
which movie I'm going to do yet might be
the Lim house Golem or it might be
um it might be the signal and a wait
further instructions like a double
feature we'll see how it goes but yeah
so thanks for dropping by and watching
us on this surprise Sunday live stream
talking about the new Godzilla movie so
we'll see you guys again uh tomorrow
night good night